speaking of saline remember she's saying
god Bless America at Super Bowl 37 in
2003 well this year Gladys Knight is
singing the national anthem maroon 5 is
performing at halftime and hey let's not
forget even if you're not a Patriots or
Rams fan there's all those star-studded
commercials cardi B taps a rhinestone
encrusted Pepsi can and Steve Carell
chuckles reading a script in the
just-released
teaser for their Super Bowl spot well
safe and guess who's joining the
Backstreet Boys
the band's all dressed up in matching
denim when chance the rapper steps in
the shot is a teaser for their jewelry
toes ad social media has made it
incredibly important for our advertisers
to get out ahead of the Superbowl to
generate buzz Sarah Michelle Gellar
returns to her screen queen roots in a
lace purse Superbowl ad called killer
skin really interesting this year it
seems like Olay bumble they're going to
be featuring more women front and center
in their commercials we have an
opportunity to take the first step
historically most of them that were
featured in ads were half-naked almost
50% of the audience that watches the
Superbowl are female and the stars are
showing their funny sides Michael Buble
stars in his first Super Bowl spot for
the soft drink bubbly
that's Buble on the floor changing the Y
in the bubbly to an e to spell his name
and you gotta love Kristin Chenoweth
teaching dogs to sing in her Super Bowl
and it's supposed to sound like this
avocados from Mexico now you gotta hit
those high notes do it again only better
this time schnauzer
[Applause]
[Music]